I'm sure you're all familiar with venmo
and the PayPal but have you ever heard
of Zell Zell was only launched in June
of 2017 but they've been putting PayPal
to shame in fact they even nearly grown
to half of PayPal size within just these
five years currently PayPal handles just
over 300 billion dollars worth of
payments every quarter meanwhile ezella
has already reached over 150 billion per
quarter something else to note is that
the average Zell transaction is worth a
lot more than the average PayPal
transaction last year PayPal completed a
total of a 19.3 billion transactions
which translated to 1.25 trillion
dollars this means that each transaction
was worth 65 on average meanwhile Zell
has completed over 5 billion
transactions within the past five years
which translates to nearly one and a
half trillion dollars this means that
each transaction was worth nearly 300
dollars on average so not only has there
been exploding in popularity but it
appears to be the app of choice for
larger payments at this rate and seems
like Zell overtaking PayPal is
inevitable but how is a new player able
to put an established giant to shame
one of the main reasons for the
popularity of Azalea is the Players
behind it Zella isn't just some startup
like stripe or a firm it's actually the
brainchild of the largest financial
institutions in the world this includes
Bank of America Capital One JP Morgan
Chase PNC Bank truest U.S bank and Wells
Fargo with such large names behind it
you might be thinking that the success
of Zelda is a no-brainer but that's
actually not the case in fact Zell was
not their first attempt at taking on
PayPal their first attempt was actually
a service called clear exchange which
came out in April of 2011. the project
was initially launched by Bank of
America JPMorgan Chase and the Wells
Fargo and it was based on the same
ideology as zala eliminating the
friction and cost associated with making
payments instead of having to use
account numbers and routing numbers you
could just use someone's email address
or phone number but despite the
promising pitch clear exchange it didn't
not translate all that well in the real
world one of the key characteristics
that makes PayPal and venmo so popular
is that they've become a verbs it's
common for people to say I can PayPal
you or I can venmo you but ain't no one
gonna be saying I can clear exchange you
and given that much of these
transactions take place amongst younger
individuals and social settings public
perception is critical aside from having
terrible branding clear exchange was
also rather clunky and slow it was
painfully evident that clear exchange
was not designed by a modern
organization to initiate transfers you
had to navigate the portals on these
bank's websites and the apps and if you
used any of these portals 10 years ago
you know how bad the UI was it wasn't
just the UI that was clunky either the
payments themselves were just as clunky
as it took up to five business days for
transactions to be completed do you know
what else takes up to five business days
to complete pretty ACH transfers it
appeared that these Banks had just
thrown together a platform that could
initiate ACH transfers using just
someone's email address or phone number
but nothing else about the service stuck
out something else that we should note
is that clear exchanger offered no real
benefit to most users one of their
largest selling features was that there
were no fees to send money but the
problem is that PayPal nor venmo charge
any fees to send money to friends or
family either so really there was no
reason to use clear exchange from the
average person's perspective venmo was
already popular amongst their friend
groups transfers took less than five
days to complete the UI was a magnitudes
better and as far as they were concerned
it was free so there was really no
incentive to make the jump to clear
exchange at first the banks thought that
the reason for this failure was a lack
of participating members so they worked
on growing the size of their network but
eventually they realized that what a
clear change needed wasn't more
fundamental features what it needed was
a facelift and that brings us to the
introduction of Zell
the first problem that cell addressed
was The Branding shortfall they changed
the name from a clear exchange to zelm
Zell was not only easier to pronounce
than venmo and the PayPal but it was
unique and memorable as it started with
the Z the old branding wasn't the only
thing that the banks Left Behind either
they also more or less ditched their
institutional business remember how we
discussed that clear exchange was free
well it wasn't just cost effective for
individual users it was also cost
effective for institutional users unlike
PayPal and venmo so the banks were very
much hoping that businesses and
governments would start using the
service and that this would prompt
consumers to use it as well but this is
rarely how things work out it's almost
always the other way around institutions
usually shift to what their consumers
want this is precisely why businesses
like PayPal visa and MasterCard are so
successful consumers want to use them in
the business says have to pay the price
clear exchange was looking to eliminate
the price for businesses but that
doesn't make the service any more
popular amongst consumers the banks
eventually realized this with Zella and
they pretty much ditched the services
Market altogether instead it Zella is
only intended for paying people that you
already know it and to trust in fact
they all disclaims any responsibility
for goods and services that are bought
through their system while this might
sound like a disadvantage this is what
actually allows Brazil's biggest selling
feature by keeping the checking and
verifications to a minimum Sal was able
to allow for instant transfers this
feature was actually launched under
clear exchange but Zella is what became
known for it this was really a zealous
Checkmate move because this was
something that PayPal simply couldn't
compete with at least not very easily
PayPal would essentially have to become
a bank if they wanted to allow for
instant transfers PayPal has very much
moved in this direction but they still
haven't been able to eliminate instant
transfer fees altogether currently they
charge a 1.75 for instant transfers
something else that makes it all
especially appealing is that you don't
really have to create an account to use
it virtually everyone in the US already
has a bank account with a result
participant so all you have to do is
enable the Zell future within your bank
account this also means that payments go
directly to your bank account so you
don't have to deal with the nominal sums
of money just to laying around in your
PayPal account to be honest none of
these are groundbreaking changes from
clear exchange but the facts don't lie
as a Zella is magnitudes more successful
than clear exchange it just goes to show
that how you're offering a service is
just as important if not more important
than what you're offering it itself the
banks didn't realize this a decade ago
but with Zelda they're more aware than
ever which has given PayPal and event
mode are run for their money
foreign
like the perfect option for money
transfers but like always there is
another side to the story as well for
one zele does not offer any sort of
consumer or Seller Protection which
makes it virtually useless for small
businesses and Merchants now we
shouldn't note that PayPal services
within this Velma aren't that great
either in fact it's actually terrible
and it seems like PayPal almost always
hides with this camera regardless of
whether this camera is a customer or a
merchant and this is why PayPal has a
trustpilot review of it just 1.3 but
with that being said at least with
PayPal there is a system with Zella the
system is non-existent this is likely
something that Zeal is working on in the
background but as of right now if you
want some sort of transaction protection
you're gonna have to go with PayPal not
only will you not have transaction
protection with the cell here's the
thing this Zella offers an instant
transfers directly into anyone's bank
account that's like a scammer's dream
right there and let's just say scammers
have been hard at work trying to exploit
Dell their latest cam tactic is known as
the payer self scam this cam starts with
a text message that alerts you that your
bank account may be at risk if you
respond to this message this camera will
pretend to be a bank representative and
will ask for a one-time verification
passcode to secure your account what
they're actually doing though is
enrolling their bank account through
Zella using your phone number and email
this means that the next time someone
sends you money through Zealot it goes
it directly to this camera's bank
account and with the average Zell
transaction clocking in at nearly 300
this becomes quite an issue the banks
are looking to stand behind Zella and
have been refunding these transactions
but this has been quite expensive 255
million dollars expensive to be exact
now you could argue that this amount
found is it nothing in comparison to
bank's net income and that is true but
here's the thing Zello doesn't produce
any Revenue whatsoever and there is no
clear path to generate Revenue moving
forward either so it's kind of hard to
justify these expenses I mean they're
basically spending all this money just
to protect their market share even that
argument is a bit iffy given that it's
not like people are opening Wells Fargo
accounts just to use them really the
only thing that Dell is accomplishing
for these big Banks is preventing PayPal
from Gaining too much power against them
for larger Banks like Chase and Wells
Fargo that's probably a worthwhile
investment but this hammock cannot be
said about smaller Banks it appears that
these institutions will be kicked out of
the system if they don't agree to
reimburse victims so it looks like
they'll have no choice but to
participate all of this Probably sounds
like a good thing for consumers but is
it
foreign
is truly an exceptional service all of
this brings us back to ground zero one
of the biggest appeals of using
alternative financial institutions is
that it takes power away from the big
Banks but embracing Zello does the exact
opposite not only will the Big Bangs
have control over our savings and the
loans but they'll also have control over
our transactions and at this point
nothing short of a Black Swan event
could stifle the growth of Zell if the
banks launched some sort of transaction
protection further down the line this
will simply make Zealot even more
appealing something else to note is that
the Zella has a much better shot
internationally than PayPal ever did
thanks to the members behind it UBS for
example would likely have a much harder
timer turning down Chase Wells Fargo
Bank of America and basically the rest
of the US banking system then just
turning down PayPal in the end Zola's
popularity is really not surprising the
Big Bangs are basically just Flex seeing
their financial Power by offering a
phenomenal service for free while they
did have some struggles in their early
days they even more than figured those
out and now they're looking to overtake
PayPal but even that is just the first
step it appears that the real goal of
Zelda is to eventually challenge a Visa
Mastercard and American Express for
decades banks have been reliant on these
payment processors to complete Merchant
transactions but the zeld could change
all of that and looking at Jamie
Diamond's pay by Bank Vision it looks
like this is very much where the
industry is heading but that's just what
I think are you a fan of Zell comment
that down below also drop a like if you
wish that we could enjoy the benefits of
Zelda without giving Banks even more
power and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community it suggests
pretty pretty ideas and to consider
subscribing to see more questions at
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign